That's good.
Good.
Okay.
So, you would just start by having used the name and the date and other issues.
My name is Steve Lawson.
Today is August 26, 2011, and we're in a conference room at the Valley Library.
Okay.
So, today we'll be talking primarily about your interactions with one of the following, specifically,
trying to get a better sense of following sort of personal characteristics.
But before we get into that, to be able to be able to talk to the world about your life, starting out with sort of a thumbnail and sketch of your biography before you into the FBI in 1991.
I was born in Pennsylvania in 1951, and lived there for the first few years of life.
I remember collecting donations for the Little League, World Championship, those typically held in Williamsburg, Pennsylvania.
And Little League is a big activity in that area of North Central Pennsylvania.
We moved to Massachusetts along the coast north of Boston in the mid to late 1950s.
I'm not exactly sure of the date.
But I went through elementary school in high school in Topfield, Massachusetts, which is a town in Essex County, very close to the sea coast.
We lived in Ipswich, originally, which is a coastal town in Essex County.
After graduating from high school, I went to Stanford University, and I was there in Palo Alto from 1969 to 1973.
I started work at the Linus Poly Institute of Science in Medicine in 1977, and took a full-time job there in February of 1978,
and had a number of different job titles there through the years.
Eventually, becoming Chief Executive Officer in 1993, about a year before Linus Poly died,
and I've worked at the Institute for most of my career.
What do you do with all your interest in science or about the student in the career?
Well, that's an interesting question.
I was a little rudderless.
I would say in college it was very difficult for me to focus on a career.
Some of my friends were very career oriented, and became physicians, lawyers,
went on to business school and so forth.
And that's pretty typical for an environment of academic excellence like Stanford University.
There are a lot of high achievers there.
And I myself was a high achiever of course in high school.
California was a big adventure for me coming from the relatively stayed and conventional east coast.
And it was very wild time to be in California in 1969 through 1973, both culturally and politically.
It was a lot of anti-war activity in sentiments.
And of course the counter-culture was really thriving in California at that time.
In high school, I was very interested in science and took advanced calculus and physics and chemistry and biology.
With the idea of perhaps becoming an architect, which led me to apply to Rensalera Polytechnic Institute as one of my college choices,
because they had a very strong department of architecture.
Stanford at the time had a department of architecture as well.
And I decided ultimately to go to Stanford.
And after I got there within a year, they had completely dismantled the department of architecture.
So that pretty much pulled the rug under, out from under me, would respect to that initial potential career choice.
I like science very much. I've always been very curious about nature and how things work.
And I think with respect to a career in the Linus Poly Institute,
although I was relatively naive about Linus Poly in high school and even in my early years in college,
I had been taking vitamin supplements beginning in high school.
Actually my mom gave me one-a-day multivitamin supplements beginning probably when I was just a kid.
But then in the high school years, my friends and I got very interested in supplements.
And we're taking vitamin E and vitamin C and things like that.
So the whole mission of the Linus Poly Institute really resonated with me.
And that led me to a position there in 1977 that really was not science oriented at that time.
It was more related to analysis of the direct mail program,
which had been implemented within a few years before I joined the Institute.
And it provided a relatively steady income for a lot of the non-grant supported research that was going on at the Institute,
which of course in those days was most of the Institute's research.
So between my graduation from Stanford and the time I joined the Institute,
it was a fairly carefree and adventurous time.
I spent a year after graduation traveling around the country visiting family and friends in Florida and Georgia and Maine and New England.
I wanted to see the country, I had been very impressed with John Steinbeck's books,
travels with Charlie and others, and also Jack Carawak who grew up and is now buried in the same area in which I grew up in Massachusetts.
So both of those writers had a very strong influence, I think, on me and my desires for experience and adventure in the United States.
When I returned to California after traveling around for a year or so,
I took a series of jobs that really were not technical in nature at all.
Cost of living in those days was very low, I think, for $100 a month, I could cover my living expenses quite easily.
And I was not, as I said, career-oriented at the time,
so I did not feel compelled to go to graduate school or begin a career in earnest at that time and I didn't.
It wasn't until I joined the Institute that I really started to focus more specifically on science,
which, at that time, really thrilled me.
Were there any, you mentioned, your interest in supplements and your college diets in the pond was probably somewhere where I was at the time.
You've been graduated with, is that true?
And are there any other signs that are going on or something?
Well, I began taking vitamins, probably, in an irregular way, when I was in high school.
Probably, you've seen your high school in that continued on into my early years,
and college.
Of course, Pauling had written vitamins in the common cold in 1970,
and friends of mine had open health food stores,
and had supplement products as part of their merchandise for sale.
So I was aware of this whole field early on,
without really knowing specifically much about wine as Pauling.
As a matter of fact, I knew very little of wine as Pauling,
even when I went to Stanford as a freshman,
it wasn't until probably about 1972 that I became more aware of him,
and it didn't have anything to do with science.
At the time, I don't believe he was teaching undergraduate courses in chemistry at Stanford,
which would have been my possible exposure to him.
I don't think he was teaching graduate level courses at Stanford either.
But he was very politically active.
And of course, this was during the lot of pretty vehement,
anti-war protests around the country,
and Stanford was no exception to that kind of activity.
And in particular, there was a tenured professor of English,
H. Bruce Franklin, who was a Melville scholar,
one of the world's foremost authorities on Melville,
and has subsequently done a lot of work in recognizing science fiction
as an appropriate academic discipline for study.
And he had joined the Revolutionary Union,
and also Venser Amos, which was an organization I believe,
based in Redwood City, California.
They were very politically active.
They were kind of Maoist organizations,
and they really wanted not only an end to the Vietnam War,
but I think more dramatic upheaval in the federal government at that time.
And Stanford eventually had had enough of H. Bruce Franklin,
and considered, I think, some of his activities borderline legal,
and Franklin was getting in a lot of trouble,
and they decided to fire him.
And of course, he was a tenured professor,
so that was a big word deal,
and protocol that they had to work through in order to fire him.
Stanford trustees at the time were quite conservative.
And I remember walking to class,
down at the quadrangle,
Stanford, and I saw a protest outside the president's office,
and there were a group of undergraduates,
and other people assembled around a couple of people waving protest signs.
And the signs had something to do with the university had no right to fire,
a tenured professor for his political activity.
And I saw these two fellows holding these signs,
and they looked grandfatherly to me at the time,
and one was Linus Pauling,
and the other one I believe was Hal Holman,
who was chairman of the Department of Medicine at Stanford University Medical Center,
who was a liberal and a good friend of mine as Pauling's at the time.
And I remember being very impressed with the fact
that these two elderly gentlemen were taking the time
out from their busy schedules to go
and actually protest in front of the president's office.
I thought that was quite remarkable,
because at that time,
most of the political activity was concentrated
among very young people.
Sometimes it was very random and chaotic,
and incoated as well,
but I thought it was quite remarkable
that there were older people who were also interested in demonstrating
for the rights of people to express their political opinions.
So that was my first,
that was really my first awareness of Linus Pauling,
was from the political perspective,
and not really from the scientific angle.
It wasn't until I joined the Linus Pauling Institute,
that I really became much more familiar with Linus Pauling's work
in chemistry and biology.
Well, when I went to Stanford,
as I mentioned, I was very interested in architecture
as a potential career,
so I was taking engineering and architecture
while that department lasted.
And I also had kind of a Renaissance concept
of undergraduate education.
I thought it was very important to take as many courses
in different subjects as possible,
so I was taking calculus, biology, and art history,
literature, and poetry, and just everything that I thought
I should be exposed to as an undergraduate.
I graduated with a degree in anthropology in 1973,
but I probably had almost enough credits
in biology for a degree in biology,
or at least a minor in biology.
And at the time, there were a couple of
pretty notorious professors at Stanford
who made a big impression on me.
One was Colin Pitt and Drake in the biology department.
He, I believe, also was director of the Hopkins Marine Station
in Monterey, taught a terrific course in biology,
and also Cachadorian William Dement,
taught a very popular course in Sleeping Dreams
that was very popular among undergraduates.
Phil Pzambarro, of course, was teaching
popular psychology course at the time,
and he went on to some famous
the leader of the Stanford Prison Experiment,
which was quite influential at the time.
How did you come to know about
the land plans to do in the job of building whiteboards?
Well, I had lived in Memo Park,
or Palo Alto for many years.
The Institute was founded in 1973
on Sandhill Road.
Opposite the Stanford Linear Accelerator.
And at that time, that part of Sandhill Road,
primarily the northern side of Sandhill Road,
headed west, was a series of relatively new buildings
on Tom Ford property.
He was a trustee of Stanford University.
And there were publishing companies
and real estate companies and insurance companies.
Now, that area is a hive of venture capitalist activity.
But the Institute, in those days,
I believe a 2700 Sandhill Road shared
relatively modern office building
with Kemper Insurance Company.
And I was aware of the sign out on the street.
So I'd driven by there many times
on my way to the coastal range or to the beach.
And I think that, if I remember correctly,
I saw an advertisement in the paper,
specifically for a job without a lot of detail
description about the nature of the job.
And I went to interview at the Linear's Plan
Institute of Science in Medicine and interviewed
with Art Robinson, who was then the president
and director of the Institute.
And he hired me.
Do you recall the first time you met my phone?
Well, the first time I saw him, of course,
was, as I said, back in about probably 1972,
when he was demonstrating against the firing
of H. Bruce Franklin.
I met him in 1977 because my office
was just off the hallway that Pauling took to get to his office,
which was adjacent to Art Robinson's office,
and also the accountant and controller
were down at the end of that office as well.
And he was very aware of who was working
at the Institute and what all the activities were
and he stopped to introduce himself to me
when I was sitting in my office one day.
And of course, I had remembered him from Stanford.
And I had become more aware of his scientific legend,
of course, by then, by working
at the Linear's Plan Institute.
And I was also aware of the fact that this was his Institute
and he was named after him.
So, of course, I had, I had high regard for him
as being the founder of this organization
that I was now working for.
But he impressed me as a very warm, charming,
very friendly person.
He was not cerebral or distant at all,
not a Louvre.
He was very, very welcoming.
What's he frequently around the Institute
and I know he traveled a lot,
but he recall him being a regular friend.
He did travel quite a lot, but I do remember him
being a regular presence.
Certainly when he was in town,
he would come by the Institute that was his office
and his main base of operations.
And if he had to do interviews or see guests,
it was typically at the Linear's Plan Institute in his office.
And I remember meeting many of his friends at that time,
including an emissary from St. George's Lab at Woods Hole.
I believe his name was.
I can't think of his name right now.
It started with a P.
It was very interested in telling us
about St. George's new theories regarding vitamin C
and the electronic basis of life.
Vitamin C is an electron donor being very essential
to life far above its role in preventing scurvy
or as an antioxidant.
Dorothy Hodgkin also came through the Institute at that time
and it was fairly soon after I arrived at the Institute
that I also met you in Cameron,
who of course was a Scottish surgeon
who was collaborating intensively with one
as Pauling on vitamin C and cancer work.
I did.
I met Dorothy Hodgkin.
At that time, I believe I was working in the laboratory.
I had begun a friendship with a biochemist named Alan Sheets
at the Institute as well as Dick Willaby.
He was a biologist working on the skin cancer
and vitamin C experiments that Pauling had designed
and were being carried out by Art Robinson at the time.
As arts influence in the Institute started to wane,
people responsible for a lot of the biological biochemical work
were encouraging me to get more involved in that work.
I seemed to have the aptitude for it.
I was quite interested in it.
I moved out of the role that I was originally hired
to perform at the Institute,
which was the direct male solicitation work and analysis,
into kind of a research assistant position in the labs.
That led me to come in contact with people that Pauling
would bring through the laboratory to show them the work
that we were doing.
Bill Aberth at the time was running a volcano source
of the organization, Mass Spectrometer,
which was used for metabolite profiling,
which was a big chunk of the Institute's research at the time.
So people were always interested in coming down to the first floor
and seeing that group Goldberg contraption,
which was always undergoing tinkering.
Never seemed to be quite ready for routine biochemical experimentation.
And since I was working in the laboratory at that time,
I would meet people that Pauling would bring through the laboratory
and one of them would dorthy Hodgkin.
So Pauling, you were hired in 1977 and LPI
and have built a career there of Pauling live
until 1994.
So at that time, in the year period,
I'm wondering if you can just generally characterize
your relationship with Pauling already all over the year.
Sure.
Well, originally I saw little of him
because my work did really not overlap
with his research interests.
I mean, of course, he was heavily involved
in the financial status in the Institute.
And Art Robinson was the main force
behind the direct mail solicitation program.
But Pauling was certainly aware of that.
And once I started working in the laboratory
more, we had more to talk about.
And I became heavily involved in the skin cancer
and hairless mice program, which was testing the effect
of different levels of vitamin C in a mouse child diet
on the development of skin cancer
in hairless mice exposed ultraviolet light.
And other arms of those experiments
and there were a number of experiments that took place
over a number of years.
Some of the other arms of that project
involve feeding raw food and nuts
to mice to see whether that also
inhibited the development of skin cancer
when the mice were exposed to ultraviolet light.
So the mice were given things like carrots
and pears and sunflower seeds
and tomatoes and other raw food
to find out what effect that would have.
And when Art Robinson left,
Pauling, of course, was interested in finding out
how this work was going.
And he asked me to, I believe the first project
that he asked me specifically to get involved
and was to calculate the amount of certain micronutrients
in the food that these mice were fed.
Because as scientists, we tend to be a little reductionist.
We want to find out if there is an effect
with the whole food, then what is it in the food
that might be protective?
So that was a very challenging project
that Pauling gave to me.
And I was a bit frustrated
because the way that the food had been provided
to the mice made it very difficult
to determine how much an individual mouse
consumed of any particular food stuff.
The mice were also caged five to a cage.
And there were social patterns that developed
of hierarchy that developed within the cage.
So there were dominant mice
who would eat the preferred food.
And then the less dominant mice would get
was left.
So there was some competition for the best food,
the most flavorful food for the mice.
The way the food was provided to them
was sometimes as a mush ground up
or blended food and sometimes as chunks of carrots
and peppers and so forth.
The sunflower seeds were given to them
and small glass containers
with metal lids that had a hole in them.
And the mice would spray the sunflower seeds
out all over the place.
And it was really impossible to determine
the intake of any of these foods for specific animal.
And even for a cage of animals,
divided by five was really not appropriate.
Calculation.
There was a lot of waste.
So a lot of the food would fall through
the mesh to the floor, to the cage rack.
And sometimes they would defecate
and urinate in the sunflower seed containers
or as well.
And then wouldn't continue to eat
once they'd already defecated or urinated in that container.
There were other issues as well.
For instance, the vitamin A content of carrots
can differ appreciably depending upon how long the carrots
are stored after they've been picked.
And that was something that was not measured at the time.
So there was no analysis,
biochemical analysis of the food
that was provided to the animals.
And depending upon the variety,
ripeness, length of time,
something that had been stored,
whether it was refrigerated or stored at room temperature,
the micronutrient content of the foodstuffs
provided to the mice can vary appreciably.
So I made the calculations,
and I sat down with Linus Pong and told them
that in my estimation it was really impossible to glean
any really useful detailed information about the micronutrient intake
of these animals.
And the best we could do was say that the raw food diet
seemed to be protective,
but it was just too difficult to determine
what constituents the raw food diet conferred that protection.
So it was a little bit,
I was a little bit ambivalent about that.
I think I did a very thorough and good job
in making these determinations,
but ultimately what I had to say was a little bit
disappointing, I think.
And how did he react to that?
He didn't react with disappointment.
He reacted as presenting him with facts and calculations,
and he was very seemed very pleased to get the information.
It was not long after that that you and Cameron
began spending quite a lot more time
at the Institute,
and I believe that taking an apartment nearby
maybe Redwood City.
And Cameron of course was very interested
in high dose vitamin C as a jumped of therapy and cancer,
as was falling,
and they had done some clinical work together
over the years,
beginning probably in 1971,
1972,
so it even preceded the founding of the Linus
Poly Institute of Science and Medicine.
And Cameron was concerned with some of the practical issues
about the administration of high dose vitamin C
patients who might also be taking chemotherapy
to drugs,
and we know that vitamin C has some general detoxification properties,
and Cameron specifically was concerned
that if people were taking chemotherapy to drugs,
then should they take high dose vitamin C
at the same time,
which might have an effect on the efficacy
of the chemotherapy to drugs.
So he didn't want to recommend to people
that they take high dose vitamin C while taking chemotherapy,
if the vitamin C was going to somehow
adversely affect these drugs.
So he wanted to find a way to study this,
and in association with Linus Poly and Alan Sheets,
we came up with the idea of using fish toxicology experiments,
which is a pretty well-established model for studying pollution
and streams and lakes and bodies of water and things like that.
So we read a lot about fish toxicology,
Alan and I figured out how to reconstitute water
from distilled water by adding back certain salts
to provide the proper habitat for fingerling trout.
And the idea was that we would have fingerling trout
that would be exposed to vitamin C
and chemotherapy of drugs dissolved
in their water that they were living in.
And we would monitor any observable effects in the fish,
and we hypothesized that they would be detected
by abnormal behavior in the fish,
which would have to do with the way they swim,
the distance that they cover in a certain period of time,
and so forth.
So there was some technology that was also developed
to make these kinds of measurements.
So that was another project that I worked with,
U and Cameron Anlan is following.
Unfortunately, we had to vacate the building
at 2700 Sandhill Road in Menlo Park,
ostensibly because there had been cracks in the building
due to smaller earthquakes over time.
It wasn't a building that was set on bedrock.
It was on loose soil.
And the landlord wanted to get the tenants out,
make some structural corrections in the building.
And I don't think the landlord was overly excited
by a laboratory in the building anyway.
We were sharing the building with camper insurance company,
and I think he was more happy with having nice dry insurance company,
and having wet labs there with animal experiments,
and physics experiments and so forth.
So those experiments had to be wrapped up
before we really brought them to fruition,
before we moved to the facility at 440 Page Mill Road in Palo Alto.
Were there other sites of the collaboration
that were following over the course of the relationship?
There were.
He would come into my office from time to time,
and we would talk about ideas he had,
different projects that he was interested in.
Occasionally he would ask me if I would be interested
in doing something like writing a book review,
which was a little surprising.
When Evelyn Richards book,
Vitamin C and Cancer Medicine or Politics,
was published, I believe, in 1991 or 1992,
Linus Pauline came into my office with a copy of the book,
and asked me if I would be interested in writing a book review
to be submitted to a nutrition journal.
And I, of course, said yes,
and wrote the review, which was subsequently published
in a nutrition journal.
Later, and of course I would go into his office
from time to time, and talk with him about different things.
The quantum chemist by the name of Zella Carmen,
who was collaborating with Pauline and problems
in theoretical chemistry and physics,
over the whole period in the late 1970s through Pauline's death.
Zella Carmen and I were both rockhounds.
We had collected rocks and minerals,
and we were kids, and we knew that Pauline was
a great mineralologist, and understood a lot
about the silicate minerals, which are quite interesting.
So the three of us would amuse ourselves occasionally
by Zella Carmen, I would bring in some of our minerals
specimens, and we would sit in Pauline's office,
and try to stump the expert, essentially.
Sometimes Zella Carmen, I would have forgotten
the identifications of some of the minerals we had,
so they would be presented to Dr. Pauline
to see if he could identify them.
It was astonishing, because even though he
had probably not thought about some of these things
in many, many years or even decades,
he infallibly was able to identify the mineral
and make a fairly quick identification.
So that was fun.
It didn't have anything to do with any of the research
going on at the Institute, but it was very fun
to sit and talk with him in that way.
Later in the late 1980s,
and I'm going to say probably around 1988,
Pauline came into my office with an idea
for a new technique to fabricate superconductive material.
And this was during kind of a heyday
or a resurgence of interest in ceramic superconductors.
But Pauline had a vastly different idea,
which had to do with the way a material
could be fabricated, and perhaps that would raise
the temperature which would be superconductive.
And it had to do with, excuse me,
phone on dampening.
And his idea was that if you could have
a conductive metal like tin,
drawn to an incredibly fine fibro, as he called it,
maybe 10 or 20 angstroms in diameter,
surrounded by insulating material like glass,
then the superconductive temperature of the tin
would be increased, the TC of the tin would be raised.
And he talked with me about some ideas that he had
and how to make this material,
which I believe would be important in supporting
a patent application that he wanted to file.
And his goal, I think, in filing this patent application,
as he described it to me and others,
was to generate a stable revenue source
for the institute.
So he wasn't interested in acquiring wealth on his own.
But he wasn't interested in looking for
revenue sources for the institute,
which had lurched from one financial crisis
throughout my whole tenure,
and as far as the two designs in medicine.
And he thought that this might be something
that could be licensed and would generate lots of income.
So Zella Kerman and I set up a laboratory
at Stanford Industrial Park at a least facility
that the institute had on Porter Drive,
which also has the Susikaawa Aging Research
facility in some storage area.
And we set up a laboratory bought an oven,
some torches, blow torches, compress gas,
borosilicate glass, tin,
and Zika developed a very interesting way
to collect the material that we were going to produce,
which was a bicycle inverted on a block of wood.
And we had taken the rubber tire off the bike rim,
and we wanted to collect this glass-clad
fibrill of tin that we would generate
with torches above the furnace,
and then connect it to the bicycle wheel
and then use the petals or a crank to turn the bicycle rim
and then we would collect in a circular fashion,
this long piece of glass that was filled with tin.
So there was a lot of trial and error involved in that,
and you and Kerman was aware of what we were doing as well.
We developed kind of a special interest in this as well.
So you and Kerman and Zella Kerman and I spent quite a lot of time
in this laboratory at Porter Drive trying to produce this material.
And it was interesting, in another way, as well,
in that pollen was very interested in seeing the laboratory notebooks,
and wanted to be sure that we were taking copious and meticulous notes
on what we were doing.
Between notebook page, for instance, had to be signed and dated,
and then periodically, I believe, once a week or once every two weeks.
Someone who was not associated with a project was asked to read
what had been put in the laboratory notebook and countersign it.
So typically, we asked him,
who was the president and the institute at that time,
to read what we'd written in the lab notebook,
and then he would countersign it and dated as well.
Which was when I was working as a scientist at the institute,
I was aware of how important it is to maintain good protocol
and filling up data and laboratory notebooks.
You don't erase things, you cross them out,
glue or tape things in, use pen, date and so forth.
So that in the future, people who are unfamiliar with your work
could theoretically be able to go back and repeat what you've done
based only on the information provided in the lab notebook.
And that was, that concept was really driven home through this work
for Linus Pauline, because he was very interested in us maintaining
very meticulous laboratory notebook,
which we did, and he was quite happy with it.
And after many months of trial and error,
and kind of a sophisticated development of this technique,
an examination of the product through high power magnification,
we were able to come up with material that we thought would be suitable.
It needed to be tested, of course, to see whether or not
the superconductive temperature had changed,
but Pauline was just ecstatic.
At that time, he was an apartment in Stanford,
and we Zeke and I were very excited,
and we brought a sample of this down to his apartment,
and he himself was very excited.
It was, I can imagine that he exhibited this kind of emotion.
Many times throughout his life whenever he made an important scientific discovery
or became aware of an important discovery that influenced his own work,
but he just looked joyful, and he immediately went over to the mantle,
fireplace, and got a big cubic pirate crystal,
and gave one to me, and gave something to Zeke,
and then said, be sure to bring your copies of General Chemistry in,
and unscribed them on the occasion of this happy discovery
and invention that we've made.
And that work formed the basis for his patent application,
and I believe his patent for novel technique for fabricating
superconductive material was awarded in perhaps 1991.
I think there were initial applications submitted as early as 1988, 1989,
but I think that the final application was granted.
The final patent was granted in 1991.
Were that technique ever employed on any of them?
Well, it would turned out to be very difficult to measure changes
in superconductivity in this material,
because if you can imagine getting an appropriate contact
between the end of this tin fibril,
it was maybe 10 to 20 extras in diameter,
it was extremely difficult.
We sent the material off to General Electric,
and it's connected.
He had contact that a number of his friends in industry
to find out if they had equipment that might be capable
of measuring, making these measurements for us.
So there were problems in actually making the measurements.
But the vice president of the Institute, Rick Hicks, at the time,
felt that since we had the patent in hand,
we should try to license it.
So he embarked on a process of trying to identify
companies in the United States that might be interesting
and licensing this technology.
And he wasn't having much success in this country.
He went to Japan, I believe,
and probably about 1991 or 1992,
and tried to shop it around there.
Also, I'm sure there was interest express,
but there was nothing that was really consummated at the time.
And it led to kind of an interesting exchange.
And at the same time, later, when Rick had returned
from Asia, some months had gone by,
Emil Zukakondo called me on the intercom,
if I would come down to his office
because we had a visitor.
And I went down to his office,
and we had someone there from the Central Intelligence Agency,
who was very interested in this particular invention,
and wanted to know why we were shopping this around in Japan,
and in other countries, rather than the United States.
And I explained to him that, well, the reason was,
we hadn't been able to find anyone in the United States
who was interested.
I thought it was quite interesting,
that the CIA seemed to know about this.
That was pretty much the end of that.
I think there was a misque later
that had to do with the turmoil surrounding
Pauling's death and succession of people in charge of the Institute
and files being shifted around and so forth.
And somehow the application to continue the maintenance fee
on that particular patent fell through the cracks.
So I think that the reason that it died effectively
was because the maintenance fee was not paid unfortunately.
Or any other site of the collaborations of no one?
Not really.
I think that the Vitamin C and Skin Cancer experiments,
of course, I was co-author of one of the papers
that resulted from that work.
And in the superconductive material,
were the two major collaborations?
How do you describe Pauling's style of the scientists
and what you use there for it?
Think in greatest strengths in the scientists?
Well, he, as many people have remarked,
had an encyclopedic knowledge of physics, chemistry, biology,
perhaps medicine, mathematics, statistics,
had an incredibly good grasp of statistics.
And that served him very well, I think, as a scientist,
because he was, as I like to say, perhaps the best embodiment
of the multidisciplinary or interdisciplinary attack
on scientific problems.
And of course, that's a buzzword in science today.
And that's what the NIH and funding agencies encourage,
just kind of team activity.
But it was remarkable that this kind of knowledge,
expansive and encyclopedic knowledge,
was exhibited in one particular person in line
as Pauling, which I think was quite remarkable.
So his memory, as well, is ability to extract references
and facts and material from other papers and so forth,
or it's being most of his life, was quite remarkable.
So I think those two things served him incredibly well
as a scientist.
And I saw that in action many times when he could cite
other literature and talk about what other people had found
and so forth.
So I was very impressed by his grasp of science
in his memory.
And he also struck me as being very courageous.
As I said earlier, my first exposure to him
in the political arena, I thought he was quite courageous
at that time.
Later I became aware of just how courageous he was
when he was facing the U.S. Senate
with respect to allegations of his lack of patriotism
or something like that.
And he basically stood them down, which I thought
was incredibly courageous.
And in another sense, he was a very courageous scientist.
When Zalik and I were working with this furnace
in the late 1980s at Porter Drive,
Pauling would come up from time to time.
And one time in particular he put on a lab coat
and put on gloves and goggles and was wielding the torch
about the 800 degree furnace as well.
He was actively engaged in this experimental project,
which I thought was quite extraordinary.
So he didn't really prefer to just sit at his desk
and think about things.
He also wanted to get hands on
when something really intrigued him or interested in.
And during the mouse, skin cancer experiments as well,
he would often come through the laboratory
just to check on things, see how things were going,
ask people questions about the work that was underway
and so forth.
He was not removed from the experimental side of things,
although clearly he was involved in a lot of other things
and didn't actually participate physically
in a lot of the experimental work in those days.
He wasn't a stranger in the laboratory.
And I witnessed that firsthand with the work
on superconductivity where he actually was
engaged experimentally.
And I think that was probably the last experimental work
that he was engaged in.
Because at that time he probably would have been
in his late 1980s.
So he was in his late 80s as well.
Over time, you, you are all these
who changed from that of scientific research
or who are more of the administrator.
And I'm wondering if you engage in
other different kinds of work with calling
and that context of the administrative.
I'm very much so.
I had been asked to become a assistant to the president
when he knew who could come.
There was president of the Institute.
At the time I was co-director with a meal
of the laboratory for research and gene regulation.
And we had a small research group.
We were looking at problems and cancer metastasis
using protein profiling techniques,
which had just recently been developed.
And we were developing instrumentation
that would allow us to increase reproducibility
and reduce noise in the experimental procedure.
And we were very interested in discovering
genes and proteins that might correlate
with the metastatic, the development
of the metastatic phenotype in both
myrine and human cancer cells.
Excuse me.
So I was also working a bit
administratively with a meal zucacondal
at that time.
And then when a meal retired from the Institute
on the occasion of his birthday,
there was quite a lot of turmoil at the Institute
because there are a number of problems.
One problem was the Institute
as I mentioned earlier, had a history of
financial instability.
And over the years, under a meal's direction,
the Institute expanded quite significantly
to include some projects that probably would not
be considered strictly in the realm of
orthomolecular medicine, of course,
in the following's.
Most, I think, the reason he set up the Institute
to begin with and something that he was
he felt strongest about.
So I think a meal may have had a desire
for the Institute to become a more comprehensive
Institute of Molecular Biological
and Chemical and Biological Sciences,
similar to the Salk Institute,
down in Southern California,
which is a fine template,
and there weren't enough grants
one by Institute staff
to support all the varied activities
that were going on.
So, concomitant with Amel's retirement
and retirement of Rick Hicks from the Institute,
there was a shift in focusing the Institute
and the Board of Trustees decided
that there really weren't enough funds
to sustain all the varied programs
underweight Institute.
So the idea was to pair back
some of the strictly molecular biological work
that wasn't funded
extramararily by government grants from DOE
or NIH or NCI or whatever.
And refocus, specifically on
orthomolecular medicine.
And at about that time,
Linus Pong had begun a friendship
and scientific collaboration
with a German cardiologist,
Matthias Rat, who
together with Pong had developed some
interesting hypotheses about the relationship
of lipoprotein A,
which is a risk factor for
orthosclerosis and a major
constituent of atherosclerotic plaque
and vitamin C.
And they published a number of hypothesis papers
of very famous one being in PNAS
and developed,
decided to set up a laboratory
for cardiovascular disease research
that was directed by Dr. Rat.
And Pong was very excited about this work.
When, at some point,
and I don't remember the exact time
but it was after a meal had retired
and Pong became for short time.
The president and director of the Institute
after a meal.
He asked me to become his assistant
and I wasn't quite sure what
that meant.
So I had written him a note
or memo asking him what he wanted me to do
and I had some ideas
mainly of administrative nature
as to things that I thought
could result in big improvements
and the way the Institute
was run and our status, financial status
and other issues.
But he disappeared to Big Sur
to his ranch down
on the coast of California
for some time.
And I felt a little adrift.
And by this time
I got into no line
as Pong Jr.
fairly well because he was
I think in the process of
getting more actively involved
in the administration of the Institute
because he recognized
his father was ill.
And there were a lot of problems
at the Institute
and he felt he should step
into help his father,
which I thought was very commendable.
And eventually I became
the executive officer at the Institute
which was similar
in function to being president
in the Institute.
And later the board appointed me
Chief Executive Officer
I think in about 1993
technically I became Chief Executive Officer.
So throughout this period
where I functioned in different
administrative roles
I worked very closely
with Linus Pong Jr.
The Board of Trustees,
and of course by that time
Linus Pong had become chairman
of the Board of Trustees
and Director of Research at the Institute
but didn't really have
an administrative role
any longer in the Linus Pong Institute
to the Science and Medicine
because I think everyone felt
that it would be best
if he were spared
the problems that we had
to resolve.
And there were problems
concerning relocation.
It was a zoning issue
where the least property
on which our building was situated
at 440 Page of Mill Road
in Palo Alto
was scheduled to
change from commercial
to residential zoning
quite quickly
and no long range plans
had really been developed
to deal with that zoning change
and we didn't have an endowment
had very little money.
So the prospect of moving
the Institute
trying to keep it intact
and the mid peninsula
but paying maybe 10 or 20 times
more in rent
was not very
encouraging
and Linus Pong himself
of course had been diagnosed
with prostate cancer
and although he was undergoing
a number of different
experimental therapies
it was not believed
that he would survive
his illness
and we were very concerned
about what would happen
to the Institute
after his death
would we would be able
to continue to raise money
to support the Institute
as a viable research organization
and then of course
there were lawsuits
and there was quite a lot
of litigation at that time
the T.S. rat had left the Institute
and it sued the Institute
for infringement
and his business activities
and also sued Linus Pong
so I had to manage
a lot of our litigation
at that time as well.
So my role
at the time
the big challenges
were finding a future home
or at least the disposition
of the Linus Pong Institute
to the science and medicine
keeping it intact
and reputable
and also managing our litigation
which was very burdensome
and took
absorbed a lot of my time
and a lot of the board's time as well
but Pauling was largely spared from that.
I mean he was deposed
of course
a number of times
but
I managed a lot of our legal affairs at that time
in close association
from Linus Pong Institute
the chairman of the board
and at that time we had
very regular board meetings as well
so the Board of Trustees
was kept well-apprised
of all the activities
and their opinions were solicited
and many of these activities as well
so
it was a very challenging time for me
I was surprised to be honest
when the board asked me
to become chief executive officer
because it kind of came out of the blue
the work that I was doing
with a musicer condo
was not really related
to work the molecular medicine
wasn't related to vitamin C at the time
as I said
we were looking at metastatic cancer
which really had nothing to do
with the molecular medicine
so I was concerned
that my group and my job
were in jeopardy as well
because
there were rumors circulating
that the board wanted to refocus
on North Molecular Medicine
and since my work
wasn't involved in North Molecular Medicine
I thought
perhaps I might be laid off
from the Institute as well
at about the same time
a musicer condo wanted to
collect
some of the people who were doing
molecular biological work
in a new institute
called the Institute of Molecular Medical Sciences
which he
hoped to rent space
from the Lyon's Plan Institute of Science
and Medicine in the same building
so I spent quite a lot of time
as executive officer
with Zelecurmin
analyzing that proposition
trying to figure out
whether it was practical
and if so
how building expenses
should be shared
between the two groups and so forth
so I spent quite a lot of time
in those kinds of deliberations
at that time too
and eventually we came up
with a recommendation
to line us calling in the board.
One of
calling
some calling
are just
about
taking away
than the Golden
years of health
equipment
to collect
and martial
overseas
tremendous talent
of scientific
resources
of the graduate students
or classmates
and I'm
wondering if you
have shared this
in one sort of
academic going on
that over the course of the month
of the year
with the release
of
quite talent
and
make it a visit
for the future.
Well
I think
our Robinson is a terrific
scientist
and art
of course was working
very close with one
as calling
at the University of California San Diego
and then came up
to run his lab
and collaborate
with research
and Stanford
and there's no question
that Dr Robinson
was an extraordinarily capable scientist
and with
calling
developed lots of very interesting ideas.
So
that was one
person
that he worked with
over that period of time
that I had
a lot of respect for
and I think
at least until
there was
big schism
that developed between them
which was very painful
to watch,
especially
at that time
I was not really
privy
to a lot of the
major administrative decisions
that the Institute
was a little unclear
as to why
it was very difficult
and uncomfortable
time
for everyone I think
at the Institute
excuse me.
Bill A. Berg
and Bill A. Berg
physicist
was also
very
extraordinarily talented
individual
with developing
the
mass spectrometer
for
metabolite profiling.
Emil Zuckerkondel
who had developed
the idea of
chemical paleogenetics
or molecular evolution
with falling earlier
in the 1960s
was an
extraordinarily bright
and capable scientist.
He was also
the founding editor
of the Journal of Molecular
Evolution
and
was
one of those
rare individuals
who's capable of
sustaining simultaneously
many complex thoughts
and I saw this
in action many times
I have tremendous
respect and admiration
for in those of
these
the evidence
and some of
the scientific
and theorists.
The
were people
extraordinarily
high caliber
that were involved
and of course
the collaborations
as well
and some of Paul's collaborators
were visiting a institute from time to time.
There were a few
problems
in that
since the Institute
did not have
stable financial resources
dominant. It was difficult to attract high caliber scientists. The war high
caliber scientists who were employed at the Institute John Levitt, Jim Fleming,
Greg Spicer, there were a number of people that were very, very good, you and
Cameron as a medical director, but it was difficult because not much could be
offered to people other than at-will contract, which was the way that the most
contract, most employment is handled in California, unless you have an employment
contract and it was imprudent to offer employment contracts to people. So initially
it was kind of an implied at-will employment arrangement with people and then later
in the early 1990s it became very explicit at-will employment relationship with
employees. But nevertheless there were people who were attracted to the Institute
because of Linus Pong because of it is interesting vitamin C, Dr. Connie Chao and
others who did a lot of really terrific work, Wolcott.com, just to mention a few,
but there were a number of really excellent people there, physicians and scientists who
did a lot of very good work over the years. And in those days it was also very difficult
to get, expect, and get funding from the National Institutes of Health or the National
Cancer Institute for the kind of work that Pauling was especially interested in, which
had to do with vitamin C and cancer. So I'm sure you're aware of his difficulty in getting
grants to carry out this kind of research with the very promising clinical work that
Cameron had been doing in Scotland, Pauling and Cameron went to the NCI with that work repeatedly
and they suggested that he apply for funds to do animal work and so-called work and he applied
for those funds and then was turned down repeatedly over seven or eight consecutive years.
So the money that was supported that kind of work at the Institute was sought from the
public through this direct mail solicitation campaign and that was the money that was available
to pay the researchers who were doing that work.
Pauling is also famously being a critical lecturer. I wonder if you could comment on that
your experience in being in the lecture and is this only in that regard?
Yes, I didn't see him lecture very often. I saw him give lectures at Stanford University
and of course he would give the famous vitamin C lecture where he would stand on stage and
pull from his, he typically wore a three-piece suit when he was giving a lecture, a dark suit
sometimes he would wear his beret and he would invariably begin his lectures on a vitamin
C by pulling out a vial, a test tube and holding it up with his fingers with a very small amount
of a white powder at the bottom that was barely detectable from the audience perspective
and you would say this represents the RDA for vitamin C, this is the amount of vitamin C that
the Food Nutrition Board believes that people should get every day and he would follow that
by pulling out a large test tube with 13 grams of vitamin C in it and you could obviously
see all this white powder in the vial from across the auditorium and he would say this is the
amount of vitamin C that a goat synthesizes on average every day. I think goats know more about
nutrition than the Food Nutrition Board and of course that always got a big round of applause
and chuckles from the audience. One lecture I saw him give which really stood out in my mind
was a lecture departmental lecture to biostatistics at Stanford and that department was
chaired by Byron Brown who was a leading biostatistician and the Stanford Department of Biostatistics
is world-renowned. They've been world-renowned for many decades and Byron Brown was the father of
classmate of mine from Stanford so I knew him and he had become aware of Pauling's work with
Abram Hoffer on a regimen provided adjunctively to cancer patients since included not only
vitamin C but also B vitamins, vitamin E, zinc and some other things and Pauling and Hoffer
had published two papers on this regimen and Pauling believed that it was even more effective than
the soul use of vitamin C which was given either intravenously or orally sometimes both by
Ew and Cameron and Scotland and they had and Pauling had developed a statistical analysis of this
data based on work done by an old friend of his from UC Berkeley by the name of Harden Jones
and Pauling believed that this statistical analysis was better than the standard
Kaplan Meyer mortality analysis because by using Harden Jones analysis you could actually
resolve subcohorts that had similar death rates and you might be able to learn more about these
subcohorts with similar death rates so he thought that this was was a better way to analyze mortality
data from from clinical studies and he published also I think was Ellicurman and perhaps it was
PNAs on and this Harden Jones analysis of mortality data and he was invited by Byron Brown to give
a lecture to the biostatisticians at Stanford on this Harden Jones mortality data and of course
at the time everybody was using Kaplan Meyer which is the standard step staircase type curve
that you see published in papers and I went with Pauling and Herman to that lecture which was
in a large conference room over at Stanford and it was astonishing how little criticism he got
from this analysis I think he was prepared to be well he was never really defensive about anything
because he was very sure was on intelligence and his own analysis but no one had any serious
criticisms of his analysis and people were saying that while perhaps we should we should look at this
more carefully and perhaps this does offer a better alternative to Kaplan Meyer analysis and some
circumstances it was quite extraordinary quite extraordinary to see some of the world's leading
biostatisticians react that way to something that was fairly novel and something that was certainly
not standardly employed in this kind of analysis and it was quite interesting to see him present that
analysis. I'm wondering if you could speak a little bit more about Pauling of the mentor as well
as your software and the others you saw. He was very encouraging and as I said he was not a
loop so it was very easy person to speak with. I think at the time that I got to know him of course
he was in his 80s and at that time he was considered kind of an icon in science and everyone was
extraordinarily respectful to one as Pauling. No one at the Institute called him by his first name
for instance it was always professor Pauling or Dr. Pauling even Dorothy Monroe the secretary
and assistant called him Dr. Pauling and typically he's eloquent I'm going to call him professor Pauling
Amy Ozzercocondo typically called him Dr. Pauling as to Rick Hicks and so I think that was
a measure of respect that all the people at the Institute had for him. He was also very interested in
people in a personal basis as well and I remember when he had decided not to drive so much himself
anymore from his apartment on Stanford campus to the Institute which was just a mile or two away
people would volunteer to drive him from his apartment to the Institute and then take them back
to his apartment at the end of the day and I did that quite often because I enjoyed talking with him
and I also enjoyed to have an uninterrupted period with him where he was free from telephone calls
or appointments and other distractions because there were a lot of demands on his time throughout his
career I imagine and at the Institute there were always people calling wanting to interview him
wanting him to get lectures and so forth and wanting to visit him so was rare to have an occasion to actually
talk with him one on one with no distractions and he would occasionally ask me about my long-term
aspirations and make suggestions and he would often tell me stories he loved to tell stories about things
that had happened to him that were based on work that we were doing at the Institute or that
might have been stimulated by a comment I would make to him and I remember one time this is a
little off topic because doesn't do a mentorship but I think it gives you some insight into his sense of humor
during one of these trips where I was taking him to the Institute and he told me that he had been
over at the Stanford Library to look at an old issue of nature or science from close to the early
part of the 20th century close to the turn of the century and this was when David Star Jordan
was present in the Stanford University of Leeland Stanford was chairman of the board.
David Star Jordan was an ornphologist excuse me itch theologist who had written books on
academic books on fish and he was present in the university at that time as well as being a scholar
and Pauling had been looking through an old issue of nature and for a specific article but this
other story caught his eye and it had to do with a controversy that had developed at Stanford
between David Star Jordan and Leeland Stanford and Leeland Stanford apparently had become
unhappy with David Star Jordan because during trustees meetings Jordan did not refer to the
trustees by name and Stanford thought that this was not civil and perhaps even borderline
rude not to refer to them by name and he had implored Jordan to learn the names of the trustees
and in subsequent meetings to refer to them by name and Jordan's retort apparently to Stanford
was well I'm afraid if I enforce to memorize the name of a trustee I'll forget the name of a fish
and Pauling thought that was hilarious and it gives you an idea of what he valued
because I think he was definitely on the side of Jordan in that argument
I just think do you recall any other stories from the drive time?
Oh there were lots of other stories one time wasn't during a drive but it was when
I was negotiating in contract with Unilever and Elizabeth Orden who had
decided to develop a line of cosmetics that included some antioxidants and wanted to
get the Institute involved in this not in a research and development capacity but they wanted to
support some research at the Institute and provide us with a lot of money and I've been talking
many times with Linus Pong about this prospect and went into talk with him in his office about it and he
said oh he remembered one time that he and A.V. Helen had gone to visit Lord Leaver in England
and had brought along a bottle of Scotch whisky as a present and it was in their bag and they got
to Lord Leaver's castle or home and they were met by servants who immediately took their bags
and they were ushered in to see Lord Leaver and Pauling in his wife were chatting with him
and Pauling remembered that he had a gift so he wanted to excuse himself and go to his room
and get the gift for Lord Leaver and went up to his room and the servants had already unpacked their
bags put clothes in the drawers or hanging in the closet and they'd also taken out the bottle of
whisky and uncapped it and had two jiggers there ready for Pauling and it's a wife because they
believe that Pauling brought this long to serve himself so he thought it was very funny that he had to
present Lord Leaver where the bottle of whisky that had already been opened but he explained to him
why it had been open and one other story that I thought was quite indicative of Pauling's character
was told to me by you and Cameron and Cameron of course had been collaborating very closely with
Pauling and Pauling had decided to visit Cameron as home in Walk Woman's side
on a trip that he was making to England and Cameron told me that he was a little bit ambivalent
about this visit by the great man of science to his humble home in Scotland he was worried that
it wouldn't be presentable enough so he and his wife made elaborate preparations to welcome
Linus Pauling and his wife to their humble home in Scotland and the day that Pauling arrived
Pauling arrived and within half an hour before Pauling had arrived the toilet stopped up
and Cameron hadn't had time to do anything about it before the arrival of Linus Pauling and his wife
so Pauling and his wife arrived and they came in and pleasant trees were exchanged and Cameron showed
them around the home in the view and so forth and Pauling asked to use the bathroom and Cameron said
which I'm very, very sorry this character is quite but there seems to be a problem with the toilet
and Pauling so what's the problem and Cameron explained in the toilet had just gotten stopped up
and he hadn't had time to do anything and Pauling so well it's going to fix it so Cameron was
a bit of gas but said okay so the two of them went into the bathroom and and Pauling cut down
with a ranch and Cameron had the plumbers helper and Pauling had a ranch and he was lying on the floor
with working on the plumbing fixing Cameron's toilet so Cameron realized that he didn't really
need to be too careful about what he said or how Pauling was treated after that because he recognized
that Pauling was was not an aloof cerebral sort of person he didn't get his hands dirty so I
just speak so he mentioned that one year maybe the first experience of Pauling he had was
of him doing it after they would be seeing Pauling fix now why didn't he think he could
reflect a little bit more on what he saw it and then tend to just be stuck with him in the floor
of the toilet and of course he hadn't used well of course I myself was very much opposed to the
Vietnam War my brother was killed there as a fighter pilot in 1970 which really almost interfere
with me resuming my studies at Stanford because it was emotionally very difficult time
and I had never understood the logic of the war I didn't buy that domino theory that the
administration time was promoting with respect to we need to stop communism Vietnam because then
all all the countries in South East Asia will become communist in Indonesia and Japan might be
attacked and so forth I didn't buy that explanation and it seemed to me that the war had been
going on for a very long time and was resulting in a lot of misery and I couldn't see how it was
constructive I couldn't see a good outcome so I I think had sentiments that were very similar to
those espoused by Linus Pauling at the time and Pauling of course as I learned had been an
old hand in political activism originally stimulated by his concern about proliferation of nuclear
weapons and medical concerns about the effect of widespread fallout from atomic bomb testing
in the atmosphere so that that really resonated very strongly with me there were some people at the
institute who were even further left and I would consider myself in some ways conservative and many
ways liberal as well but there were some people from the institute who were I would say probably
extreme leftist and I remember in particular after one of Pauling's talks it's Stanford that was
peace-related there was quite a lot of unhappiness among some people because Pauling had made the
statement during this talk that he believed that the retention of some nuclear weapons by both
the Soviet Union and the United States and the so-called mutually assured destruction principle
had actually resulted perhaps in deterrent from having a nuclear war configuration so they were
they were surprised to hear him say that because I think some people had hoped that he would
espouse the opinion that we should destroy all weapons you know laterally and so forth but
that's not what he said in his lecture he said that he believed that having some of these weapons
by opposing forces would have probably resulted in the satisfactory stalemate because either side
was inhibited from using them knowing what would result from that first use of an atomic weapon
right and that was uh and I think in that community involved for years early on he didn't sit
I think he knows that he's involved yeah and I heard him say that several times so he definitely was not
I would say he wasn't a pacifist because he he said many times the World War II was well justified
and he as you know worked closely with a military to develop armaments and instruments that
helped the Allied effort during World War II he was certainly opposed to Hitler and Naziism and
I always saw him as a great patriot and it never occurred to me that
great patriotism and opposition to the Vietnam War or opposition to atmospheric testing of nuclear weapons was somehow
couldn't be reconciled and some people
didn't seem to be to mean mutual exclusive characteristics
we're calling for something that came up around the student mail
we talked about that with people and casual conversations with his colleagues or with his primarily
weren't they disappointed? Pauling was not someone who engaged often in small talk
so even in the many discussions that I had with him he wasn't someone who liked to talk about
pop culture or movies or music or literature or anything of that nature he loved to talk about
science and especially about things that he was interested in and he loved to tell stories and
most of the stories were related to things that interested him from a scientific basis
so I don't recall ever talking with him specifically about any political activities and
unfortunately I never thought to ask him more closely about some of his political activities
because there were always other things to talk about and I didn't really query him much about
his personal history when I knew him we're always talking about current things or things that
were going to be doing in the future and not so much retrospective issues except when he would tell
me stories based on a current stimulating conversation that we might be having but no he didn't
generally talk about political issues with the staff it was mainly related to administrative issues
and scientific issues well what was he like in the larger social settings well in
largest social settings he was often the the person that people gravitated to he had a real
charismatic personality kind of a magnetic personality he he always had a big smile he was very engaging
very warmly greeted people in the social setting was physical shook hands put his arm around
people so he was he was very engaging and people responded to that and that's why
so many people loved him over the years and when he died in 1994 the institute collected hundreds
and hundreds of cards from people that didn't know lunch point personally but had been deeply
affected by his death and were were grieving and sharing their grief with us at the time and
everyone at the institute felt the same way as well I mean it was a really when he died in 1994 it
was a very emotional moment for all of us because he just he had a way of generating a lot of
positive emotion about him and a lot of people loved him and respected him for different reasons but
he was a very jovial person he as I said he treated everyone fairly and equally I remember one time
when I was in the back parking lot of the institute Pauling was leaving
the back door and the janitor was arriving so it was after hours it was maybe five thirty or six
in the afternoon and the janitor was quite away from the door I'd say maybe a hundred feet from
the door because janitor tended to park at the far end of the parking lot and Pauling stood there
holding the door open for probably three or four minutes while the janitor navigated this distance
and came into the building and then Pauling greeted him and then left the door and he was also
holding a box because he often used a box to ferry books and papers back and forth from the
institute to his apartment or ranch so he had something that in his arm as well instead they're
holding the door for the janitor and I think that was kind of symbolic in a way of the way he treated
people he was just very fair to everyone sometimes I think his excitement about scientific ideas that
he would generate an association with particular people caused him perhaps to overlook what might
some other people might consider problematic issues in personalities and I think that this
happened to him at least twice in his later years at the institute and both times it resulted in
personal clashes very unemicable departures of personal from the institute and litigation which was
very difficult expensive and painful for everyone involved but I think he was so excited by
scientific talent that he tended to overlook some personality characteristics from time to time
but as I said it was a very warm engaging person I would go to birthday celebrations
which occurred I think every five years typically at hotel in San Francisco and there were other
occasions at which visitors were honored or the humanitarian award was given out or other awards
were given out or Pauling was an intense award and he was always very very charming and people were
very happy to see him and he always had a big smile and greeting for everyone well the birthday
celebrations were terrific the last one I remember was at Stanford Courthode Hotel in San Francisco
the mistress of ceremonies was Rita Moreno and I believe she was approached by Rick Hicks
to host that party because she had gotten an Emmy an OB atoni and an Academy Award so
Rick thought it was appropriate that someone who had been so honored in so many of the performing
fields was hosting an event for someone who had been so honored in so many medical and scientific
and social field like Lyme's Pauling and she was a real firecracker and I think Lyme's Pauling
really enjoyed listening to her talk and he had a lot of his old friends there and it was it was always
he always really enjoyed interacting with old colleagues we also had a 20th anniversary celebration
of the Lyme's Pauling Institute in 1993 at the Rings Doorhouse which was a Victorian house that had been
renovated in the salt marsh area of Mountain View California adjacent to Palo Alto and that was
an opportunity to put on display a lot of Pauling's awards medals, honorary degrees and also invite
supporters of the Institute Institute staff and friends and some of Pauling's colleagues and
friends who were still in the Bay Area to come and see him and as it turned out it was probably
the last time that some of these people had an opportunity to meet him to see him again.
Owen Chamberlain was there hard in McConnell from Stanford chemistry department who had been
a long friend of Pauling's and I think instrumental in bringing Pauling to Stanford back in 1969
was there byron Brown from biostatistics was there and there were a number of people that Pauling
had liked and associated with over the years that were there and it provided him an opportunity to
see them and greet them. He always had a lot of energy to meet people as well and
he had a very interesting way of speaking that was very characteristic and a very characteristic way
of moving as well both of which were captured quite realistically by John Aston when he performed
the part of Linus Pauling in the nature of the Marital Bond which was a play put on in association
between the Linus Pauling exhibition years ago.
Well he spent quite a lot of time of course with Rick Hicks and he meals out of the condol and I think
Rick was, Rick really went out of his way to try to take care of Linus Pauling as well as
especially after he had a hell and died. I really looked after his welfare and was interested in
his personal health as well and I think he even tried to get Linus Pauling to exercise which is
something that Pauling refused to do and he talked quite often when they meals with the condol mainly
about administrative issues. So with Rick Hicks and he meals out of the condol there was a lot of
talk about administrative issues and these kinds of conversations went on for a decade or longer.
He saw quite a lot of hardened McConnell who was someone he could talk about chemistry with and
Henry Talbe as well as Stanford. And Zoa Kerman was another person that was a colleague
and an employee of the Institute but someone that Pauling could talk in a very meaningful detailed way in depth about
theoretical chemistry and structural chemistry and physics. So Perman and Pauling co-authored quite a few
papers during this period in 1970s through the 1980s and up through the 1990s and I think Pauling relied on him to
do a lot of the sort of the heavy work in many of those papers. So he spent a lot of time with
Zoa Kerman as well and there were a lot of people that visited him who he'd known throughout his life
but he didn't really seem to have what I would call a strong social life. Of course
if he was entertaining people at his home in Porto, Vali or at his apartment in Stanford
I wouldn't necessarily have known about that. I mean I went to his home in Porto, Vali, a number of times.
He and his wife used to host Christmas parties there and one of the last Christmas parties I went
to there I think was probably 1979. Either Helen died in 1980 or 1981. 81. So I believe that
this was probably about 1979 and I remember thinking about the eggnog that Pauling made which was really
extraordinarily good. He wasn't a chef but having a Nobel Prize winning chemist, Nobel Prize winning
chemist make the eggnog and spike it with vicar was pretty extraordinary. It was a really terrific treat
and when he was with his wife was also very affectionate and I think people picked up on that
affection and responded to that as well. After his wife died of course there was no one for him to
be that affectionate with so he was a bit different in in social situation because it didn't really
have someone to to be affectionate with in those circumstances. She was a really diminutive person.
She was short. She was very well spoken, very articulate and I enjoyed speaking with her when I
talked to her several times. She and I did not talk about science so much as we talked about other
issues and she as I found out later was particularly fond of their association with some of the
celebrities and in Los Angeles and Hollywood during the era in which Pauling was trying to educate
them about radioactive isotopes and nuclear weapons and so forth and engaged in peace activities as
well and we talked I think about how I talked about those things sometimes but typically she was
very close to her husband physically whenever they were in a social environment and he always liked
to steer the conversation to science so the conversation typically would end up being about science
and not so much about so many other activities. One of the things about Pauling
that I enjoyed was when I found out that he enjoyed reading mystery novels I also was a big fan of
Sherlock Holmes and not so much I get the Christie but particularly Rex Stout and I asked him if he had
read all of Sherlock Holmes and Rex Stout and of course he had so there wasn't anything I could loan him
but there were other books that I was reading and he was not familiar with. One was called the
Red Right Hand by Joel Townsley Rogers which I think was written in 1939 or 1940 and it's a real
hard-boiled, great detective story and I loan that to him and he really he loved that book very much
and he consequently loaned me books I would loan him books and he would he would loan me mystery books
as well that he had finished reading it was very interesting then and one time he he broke from
that orthodoxy and loaning the mystery novels and loaned me a book called Good Night Ava by Richard
Bistle and this was a 1950s pulp paperback with a painted cover and he said I think you'll
enjoy this and I got the book and I read it and it reminded me a little bit of verse can
called well even Mark Twain maybe and the cover of the book showed kind of a disultry group sitting
on a on a porch of a kind of a ramshackle cabin probably in the banks of the Mississippi River
and there were a couple of guys lounging around look like near duels and there was a woman's
trimming guitar in not much on and she had her foot up on a pickle barrel or something
and I thought it was amusing that he's loaned me this book and it was actually an amusing
entertaining read as well and I gave it back to him and when he when I gave it back to him his eyes
kind of sparkle a bit and he said did you notice anything particularly funny about the book
and I said yes and both of us burst out laughing he had taken a photograph of this
wife and cut out her face and pasted it over the face of the woman playing guitar on the cover
of the book and I thought that was very funny very appropriate since the the book had Eva in the
title as well you have that book I'm sure you do yeah and he had he had a terrific sense of humor
zeal a term and likes to tell the story of the time that he was standing at the urinal
in the men's room at the line is pines to do science medicine and line is pines came in and
stood next to him and looked over and said ah we meet his peers so he was not prudish
and of course Ken Hedberg has a very famous story of when Ken was a graduate student
Caltech and was looking through one of those little plastic viewfinders the woman oh natural
and the stream standing on a rock or a boulder I mean holding this viewfinder up to the light
and he heard polling footsteps outside his office and thought oh and polling came in and of course
wanted to see what the viewfinder picture was and he held the viewfinder up to the light and said ah
basalt and he did identify the rock that she was standing on so he had a great sense of humor
and it would definitely was not prudish
just backtrack and briefly you mentioned that all he's talking about the connections that they
had with some of the Hollywood types you call any individual who is particularly fun about
the rhythm of that no I don't but I remember there were a number of people who came to the
Institute and also to some of polling birthday events and other events such as Eddie Albert remember
giving a tour to Eddie Albert and son Eddie Albert Jr. one time at the Institute and Carl Sagan came
by one time for an event and there were a number of other number of other people who escaped me
right now who came through the Institute and one reason or another but those who were I believe
after Avalan and died so those were people who had continued to have some title in his poem
or the one in his poem Institute but I don't recollect talking with her about specific people
following by all accounts at a very difficult time dealing with their own death
you have memories of that time dating how that ended so well as every call he was gone quite a lot
after her death I think he took a trip to Oregon and visited some of his old boyhood
haunts his home maybe the family cemetery maybe went to condon came here to Oregon State University
he was perhaps didn't exhibit the same sort of levity that that I was accustomed to seeing
in him in other words he was spontaneously happy in the late 1970s when I saw him he always seemed to be
very happy and very carefree I think there was a more somber demeanor that he exhibited after
her death and a lot of the sort of levity seemed to evaporate from his countenance at that time
now that slowly returned over the course of the 1980s and I'd say by the mid to late 1980s he seemed
to be pretty much his old self in terms of the good sense of humor but there was a period there
when he didn't seem to be very happy yeah that's why